meine lieben freunde heute trete ich in
vier minecraft minigames gegen mexiko 3
max und paletten an für dieses event
wurde das kännchen impact wissem update
in minecraft nachgebaut und sogar die
verschiedene minigames an genthin
angelehnt jedoch starten wir nur noch
direkt mit einem jump and run bei dem
möglichst viele kisten checkpoints
erreichen müssen
wir kommen nicht über den ersten schreck
weil man warte ich
vertraue ich drei dann nicht mehr wir zu
dritt
main gesammelt bis jetzt ich habe die
leute wenn viele youtuber versuchen
immer klammer dann wird das nichts
ich
scheiß kopfhörer
der sache was er denkt er schnappt und
dann welches runter und
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp wir hatten
jetzt mal ganz kurz durch bevor ich mich
gleich weiter bei diesen jump'n'run
aufreger erzähle ich euch das mal ganz
kurz was kännchen impact überhaupt ist
jetzt ein effekt ist nämlich ein
mehrfach ausgezeichnet das open world
game in welchem man durch die welt von
take that reist um die antworten der
sieben götter zu erhalten und sein
verlorenes geschwisterchen zu suchen und
wird dabei übrigens von timon begleitet
und baut sich eine vierköpfige gruppe
mit unterschiedlichen fähigkeiten auf
den schienen im pack ist free to play
besitzt einen koop modus ab level 16
unterstützt cosplay und bietet euch die
möglichkeit einen spielstand dinge zum
beispiel auf ps2 psp keine ahnung was
angefangen habt dann auf eurem handy os
android microsoft windows keine ahnung
was einfach fortzuführen und wir führen
jetzt allerdings erstmal das jump'n'run
weiter fort
[Musik]
du musst auch
irgendwann angefangen
zu bauen
mal haben
ich will nicht mehr ich habe die ganze
zeit meine kopfhörer abgesetzt damit ich
höre ich bin es gibt halt einmal hart
links und die sie rechts
okay wir haben wir haben vier minuten 30
haben wir doch
alles schon wieder du kannst
nicht drauf aber wo kommt denn gerade
nicht raus dieser weiterer block da
unten
ich mache gar nichts mehr ich fange kein
mehr streit und ich werde jetzt
[Musik]
sehe ich dass kopfvoran capcom junge
gewinnen zeigt ihnen das ja zwei minuten
17 2 -17 kommen und sascha gab und jetzt
drauf
um alle miteinander jetzt geschaffen ja
ich gekauft nur alles gut läuft gut bei
mir ist super patrick platzer dpa danke
dir auch auf ich ja bei mir ist auch gut
gut wir machen nun jetzt allerdings auch
direkt weiter mit dem zweiten mini game
und zwar einem wettbewerb der an das
angenehm gentian impact angelehnt ist
und wir müssen hier jetzt innerhalb von
fünf minuten so viele fische wie möglich
fangen
[Applaus]
ich rede einfach nicht mehr mit euch
sagt die mir mich da so geschockt
warum stade
werden und sehr gut geflogen punkte
metern ab -
wie flower medaillon vom lieben hey
ich habs jacobi
dankeschön jungs danke
die ja der hätten und ich fühle mich alt
ich schade ich krieg nur schade
der branche
ein jump'n'run wurde ich nur geschlagen
oder gefallen und jetzt
hast du dich auch noch die fischer ich
habe die anderen jetzt mal stumm
geschaltet ich konnte mich jetzt
komplett ein ganz schöner film stars
einzige richtig viel punkte zack zack
[Musik]
wir werden jetzt hier geht es wieder ein
krasser fisch sein das sehen wir daran
wie schnell das ganze von statten geht
es hinten richtig großer fang sein okay
lokal aufsitzer das jetzt erster zweiter
dritter 200 jetzt kommt die aufholjagd
eine stunde später
einen tag später von ganz oben nach ganz
unten
ich habe mich vorhin gemietet leute und
hab dann habe ich nur noch so fette wale
gefangen
der kommt doch so freundlich luca ich
weiß nicht ob das freundliche
einem sieg ist das dritte mini game bei
dem wir uns als minecraft blöcke
verwandelt vor einem jäger verstecken
müssen da das ganze bei mir allerdings
nicht so richtig geklappt hat
zeige ich euch besser nur die runde wo
ich der jäger war und die anderen drei
jungs sich versteckt haben
so seid ihr alle versteckt leute ja ok
jeder muss versteckt sagt setz dir ja
dass ich ziemlich guter super-g aber das
mussten sie erst mal zeigen ok mit
anlage als erstes mexiko
[Musik]
also ich sag ich
ja jetzt
hinter der kopf ist
[Musik]
der den ich gesagt dass wir nicht als
erstes finde habe ich noch gar nicht
gefunden
ich kann den zaubertrick zeigen okay
zeigte ich kann mich verwandeln
mein ski gut aus damit lasse ich dich
gewinnen danke
ehre
vor wir nun allerdings auch schon zum
vierten und letzten minigame kommen
möchte ich euch zuvor noch ganz kurz
etwas über den patch 2.6 erzählen und
zwar bringt dieses update
doch wir kommen nun endlich zum letzten
minigame für heute meine damen und
herren und zwar eine melitta rennen das
ist angelehnt an den schienen gleiter
und wir müssen nun innerhalb von zwei
minuten mit hilfe von raketen durch so
viele partikel ringe wie möglich fliegen
ok jetzt hier die meisten punkten durch
die einen sammeln der hat sie hat sich
hier gerade gut verbraucher
wahrscheinlich damit man nicht die ganze
zeit in den gleichen ein ja
wie könnt ihr das kommentieren ich kann
nicht reden um ich konstatieren
gleichzeitig deswegen habe ich dann auch
für den rest des gleitens einfach meine
schnauze gehalten
wer hat gewonnen ich habe es nicht
gesehen ich habe extra beim ganzen
fliegen kein einziges wort gesagt weil
ich dachte ich wäre gut wenn ich mich
konzentrieren und knapp vom letzten war
so schon mit den vier mini games meine
lieben freunde ich habe auf jeden fall
nicht gewonnen dennoch habe ich für euch
eine ziemlich gute nachricht denn hier
können nun bei einem großen ganzen impaq
gewinnspiel teilnehmen und neben
tastaturen mäusen et cetera auch eine
1000 euro amazon gutschein gewinnen
klingt dafür einfach ganz wie sie auf
den link unten in der infobox hier unter
dem video oder hier in der server lobby
von genthin impact server die extrem
schön ist es muss man wirklich mal ganz
kurz sagen das hab ich in meinem job
bringt nichts schön bauen können ihr
könnt ihr auf jeden fall einfach die
lobby gehen hier über die gewinnspiel
gäste auch an dem gewinnspiel teilnehmen
schaut euch generell gern mal den server
an ihr findet alle weiteren infos zu
kennen schien impact zu dem gewinnspiel
die zentrale und in der infobox die
ganzen anderen youtuber die heute mit
dabei waren ein crm experten und märkte
sind auch unten verlegen danke nochmal
danke auch an jentzsch impact dass sich
heute mit dabei sein durften wir sehen
uns